[Music]
you've been in so many iconic films and
you played so many iconic roles people
probably forget
that even you had to start out and when
you started out you
didn't always get encouragement from
studio executives isn't that true uh
yeah that's true
it was actually worse than that uh
i i
was under contract at columbia pictures
for um
150 a week
which back in in those days
was still only 150 bucks a week
it was it was ridiculous yeah but uh but
anyway
they used to use me in little
i had to do everything that they
wanted me to do and that and my first
movie role was as a a bell boy
a bell man bomb man in a hotel in a
hotel and i delivered a
note or a telegram or something to james
coburn
and my lines were
paging mr jones mr jones paging mr jones
and he
raised his hand i went over and i said
mr jones room 204
and he said yes and i gave him the note
and that was
my job right
and then there was a guy that was in
charge of what they call the new talent
program and he called me into his office
the next day and he said
sit down
kid he always called me kid he was about
four years older than me
[Laughter]
he said uh
he said i saw the rushes from yesterday
for
he said
let me tell you a story he says the
first time you're never gonna make it in
this business he said
you just forget about it you're never
gonna he said the first time tony curtis
was ever in a movie he delivered a bag
of groceries a bag of groceries you took
one look at that guy and you said that's
a movie star
and i leaned across his desk and i said
i thought you were supposed to think
that that was a grocery delivery boy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that probably didn't go over too well
he said get out of my office
which i was happy to do
and uh i didn't last that much
longer
with them yeah
that's amazing now that somewhere he's
watching this he's i mean he's just
watched your career unfold
i was in a like 15 years later and i was
in a uh
commissary at some studio and i a waiter
came over to me with a little silver
tray i only saw that in movies once and
there was a
a business card on it and i picked up
the business card and written on it was
i missed my bet
and i turned it over and it was the name
of the guy
and um
much to my great immediate pleasure
it still gives me a little bit of
pleasure now
i looked around and i couldn't figure
out which one he was
that's the best revenge yeah